barbershop the next con hits theaters in
April it's the third film in this
franchise and Ice Cube and Cedric the
Entertainer they are back but their few
new faces including Nicki Minaj Michelle
Turner hit this set to talk to the
castle reuniting a full decade later you
still pinch yourself and say I mean I
was a kid look at you yeah girl can't
you know ah
hey good things you know but you know
the things that I can do I do pretty
well and just gotten me this far I feel
blessed so here's the deal with ice
cuter he started out as a rapper but
he's a major Hollywood player now he's
producing and starring in the third
barbershop movie and it turns out he's
not a bad boss to work for what's he
like as you know the boss around here he
still got a gangsta in him but but uh
he's really a cool dude like a a smart
guy he definitely wants the best out of
everybody
just like the office show you don't just
show up and get it games seams cubes got
a knack for finding the right franchises
the first two barbershop movies earned
over 143 million dollars he co-starred
in both 21 Jump Street movies helping
rake in over 500 million and the
ride-along movies he starred in and
produced those brought in more than 275
million dollars they also helped launch
Kevin Hart into mega stardom you know he
could be doing the same thing for Nicki
Minaj with the newest barbershop when
this can't and this booty hey if I put
him out with a black and
and I'll never get tonight why always
got to take it there
where does Nicki Minaj fit into this we
wanted a new face in the barber shop you
know we were unisex now so his barber
shopping beauty shop so I was just
honored to do something IceCube I'm
quite frankly because I looked up to him
my whole life and so when this came out
I was like what of course I was you know
you